bonjour pour sa 6ème gentes dames badass
je vais vous parler d'une femme que je
trouve formidable et que j'ai découverte
par hasard à la radio alors que je
traversais le village de la comté parce
que oui
dans les autres france on a un village
qui s'appelle la comté bref rien à voir
gertrude bell est une femme que je
trouve absolument formidable même si
certains aspects de sa vie me plaisent
mois mais bref aujourd'hui on va parler
d' angleterre victorienne de moyen
orient d'empyr ottoman sur fond de
première guerre mondiale
bref on va voyager gère trop belle né le
14 juillet 1868 en angleterre dans une
famille bien bien riche la sixième
fortune d'angleterre en gros qui s'est
enrichi grâce à l'industrie et notamment
la forge
elle étudie au queen's collège de
londres puis entre à oxford où elle
obtient son diplôme d'histoire moderne
en deux ans au lieu de trois ça plus le
fait qu'elle soit la première à obtenir
une mention très bien dans cette
discipline
filles et garçons confondus ça marque un
petit peu les esprits au point que la
presse parle d'elle
gertrude était intelligente pouvoir même
surdoué passionné d'histoire de
diplomatie et de politique
à l'époque où elle étudie à la fin des
années 1880 elle n'est pas la seule
fille à oxford et les rares étudiantes
sont plutôt bien accepté là bas sauf par
quelques professeurs qui continue de ne
pas trop tolérer cette présence féminine
et exige que les étudiantes leur tourner
le dos pendant les cours gertrude est
aussi toujours accompagné dans chaque
nuit pendant ses études parce qu'elle
reste une fille de la haute société
victorienne et qu'elle ne peut pas faire
n'importe quoi et évidemment être
intelligente dans les années 1890 pour
une femme
ce n'était pas forcément très bien perçu
même si elle est persuadée que ses
diplômes ne seront pas un handicap au
moment de se chercher un mari spoiler
c'en est un pourtant elle est aussi très
belle sportive est rousse ce qui est
déjà un signe de qualité formidable le
problème avec gertrude c'est qu'en plus
d'être intelligente elle n'hésite pas à
le montrer par exemple à 20 ans lors de
ce dîner de diplomates sous elle reprend
un ambassadeur allemand devant tout le
monde parce qu'il avait employé un
mauvais termes de géopolitique
même si ses parents la soutiennent pas
mal il lui envoie quelques lettres bien
senti après ça et elle se met à adopter
un comportement qui fait un peu plus les
dix fautes de marie-mai ayant envie de
voyager elle part à l'aventuré en
amérique pacifique chine-japon pers
elles parlent persan hindous lourdes ou
japonais arabes turcs allemands français
pratiquent aussi la photographie et
l'api nisme elle était d'une grande
résistance physique et réalise la
traversée l'escaladent de plusieurs
montagnes des alpes
l'une d'entre elles le geert route spitz
et d'ailleurs baptisé en son honneur
elle s'amuse donc beaucoup mais comme
c'est une femme et qu'elle est riche
tous ces voyages ne lui permet pas
d'avoir un métier d'autres personnes
ayant fait les mêmes études qu'elle
ayant voyagé au temps serait déjà
archéologues d'explorateurs diplomate
si c'était des hommes en 1895 elle
rencontre david hogarth le mec au milieu
à gauche de lawrence d'arabie
il est lui-même archéologues co créateur
des services de renseignement
britanniques
il lui suggère alors de voyager vers l'
empire ottoman et ça change pas mal sa
vie après s'être formé à l'archéologie
elle se met à voyager pendant dix ans
elle parcourt le désert découvre
l'ancienne mésopotamie la palestine la
syrie l'arabie elle monte six
expéditions et s'attache à chaque fois a
rencontré les populations du désert qui
l'intéressent plus que les vieilles
pierres
elles voyagent donc de tribu en tribu
dressant son campement près des camps
bédouins en voyant ensuite sa carte de
visite aux chèques
or ensuite l'invité ou être reçus par
lui pour boire le thé et discuter de
poésie dans le plus grand des calmes
elle est fascinée par le mode de vie des
bédouins qui vivent dans des campements
de 60 à 70 tente quand même et le chèque
la considère comme une ambassadrice de
l'angleterre même si officiellement elle
n'en est pas une
faut dire qu'elle ne voyage pas
n'importe comment toujours accompagné
d'au moins six à huit hommes dont fatou
son second qui la suit dans chaque
expédition et voyage toujours avec ses
forces et ses jupons dans lesquelles
elles cachent des armes son argenterie
cenap sa baignoire etc
elle reste une heidi et même si elle est
sincèrement attachés aux codes victorien
se montrer comme inédit lui permet
d'asseoir sa légitimité tout en brisant
certains codes quand ils ne vont pas
dans son sens j'ouvre ici une parenthèse
qui constitue le seul point qui me
déplaît chez elle elle était très
victorienne à tel point qu'elle était
opposée au suffrage est a été même
membre d'une ligue antilles suffrages
est avant tout parce qu'elle est
considéré comme vulgaire
enfin bref en rencontrant les chèques
qu'elle obtient aussi de nombreuses
informations
elle apprend qui est maria qui est allé
hier et qui est chaque fois qu'elle
rentre en angleterre elle rend visite à
david au garde pour lui raconter tout ce
qu'elle a appris
elle n'était donc pas officiellement
agents de renseignement elle n'était pas
payé pour ça et n'était pas non plus
couverte en cas de pépin mais elle
agissait comme tel grâce à ses voyages
elle informé renseignements sur les
tensions entre les tribus mais aussi la
présence grandissante des allemands dans
l' empire ottoman qui achètent de
nombreuses concessions archéologiques et
construisent des chemins de fer à
travers le désert en 1907 elle découvre
les ruines de la cité mésopotamienne des
cats et participe aussi à de nombreuses
autres fouilles archéologiques
elle s'est acquis une solide réputation
en angleterre et aussi dans la région
qu'elle traverse pour la surnomme la
dame de bagdad où la katun c'est au
cours de l'un de ses voyages en 1911
qu'elle fait la connaissance d'un autre
archéologue les diplomates que vous
connaissez probablement tous thomas
edward lawrence alias lawrence d'arabie
à l'époque il est second sur un chantier
de fouilles dirigées par david hogarth
et les deux s'entendent tout de suite
très bien puisqu'ils partagent la
passion de lorient et du danger guerre
trouve lui apprend d'ailleurs beaucoup
de choses sur les tribus arabes
puisqu'elle a un peu plus d'expérience
que lui elle entame son voyage le plus
dangereux en 1913 où elle décide de
s'enfoncer dans la péninsule arabique
ce qui est dangereux à l'époque puisque
trois tribus bédouines se disputent le
territoire
le gouvernement britannique refuse de la
soutenir mais elle part quand même elle
est brièvement faite prisonnière en
février 1914 avant d'être relâchés et de
pouvoir repartir vers le nord elle prend
cette expédition comme un échec et deux
mois après son retour la première guerre
mondiale éclate ce qui empêche toute
future expédition
elle s'engage alors dans la croix rouge
française mais traverse une période
difficile
déjà parce qu'elle aimerait retourner au
moyen-orient et ensuite parce que le
marié qu'elle est mais de manière
platonique meurent à la guerre en 1915
mais heureusement pour elle ses amis se
souviennent d'elle et lui demande au
même moment d'intégrer les services
secrets du caire grâce à ces super
connaissance du moyen-orient et surtout
du désert du nefousa celui qu'elle a
traversés lors de son expédition très
dangereuse
en plus elle avait déjà le meilleur
réseau sur place c'est là que je fais un
point empire ottoman aussi surnommé
l'homme malade de l'europe par le reste
du monde
déjà avant 1914 lempira les mâles les
grandes puissances européennes
s'efforcer de le maintenir en vie par
peur du bordel que ça allait
venir s'il disparaissait mais commençait
aussi à tâter le terrain pour la suite
des événements c'est pourquoi les
anglais étaient très bien positionné
puisqu'il était en egypte en mésopotamie
et en inde
et c'est aussi pourquoi les allemands
s'y montrait de plus en plus présent
avec le déclenchement de la guerre tout
le monde pressent donc le bordel que va
vite devenir cette région au caire
gertrude ii retrouve lawrence d'arabie
dont le projet est de s'allier avec les
tribus arabes notamment les hachémites
pour attaquer les turcs par le sud elle
lui fournit donc pas mal d'informations
sur les tribus à contacter et leur
emplacement et le reste vous en auriez
un aperçu en regardant le film de david
lean pendant que laurence fait ses
affaires dans la péninsule
elle est envoyée à bassora où elle
dessine des cartes en tant qu'officier
de liaison puis à bagdad
le problème est qu'en échange de l'aide
de ces tribus arabes j'ai retourné
laurence avait promis une nation à ces
tribus c'était dans l'air du temps en
1915 né en 1916 accords secrets de
s'explique au partage et au proche
orient entre la france et le royaume uni
peu de gens sont au courant de ces
accords qui sont révélés au public en
1917 et même s'ils ne sont finalement
pas vraiment appliquée gertraud dès lors
en sont loin ont le sentiment d'avoir
trahi les populations concernées
tous deux sont pour l'indépendance des
peuples arabes et le font savoir en 1919
gertraud dre déjà rapport sur la
mésopotamie et commence à parler du
futur irak et de qui pourrait le
gouverner en 1921 elle est conseillère
de churchill lors de la conférence
internationale du caire dans le camp des
orientalistes ceux qui défendent les
intérêts des arabes on la voit ici avec
churchill et laurent toujours en 1921
elle et laurence des signes des
frontières de ce qui devient l'irak
ce nouveau pays et destinés aux
hachémites puisqu'ils ont aidé le
royaume uni pendant la guerre et
gertrude insiste pour mettre sur le
trône faysal premier d'irak
dans la même foulée et créait la
transjordanie bien sûr confié ces pays à
des locaux est dans l'intérêt du royaume
uni qui vise principalement les champs
de pétrole qu'on trouve là bas b
l'intervention de gertrude a été
décisive
après la création de l'irak elle
conseille le roi faysal au début de son
règne
ce qui lui vaut le surnom de reine sans
couronne d'irak elle est très attaché à
ce pays
allant même jusqu'à se considérer comme
la première irakienne
du fait de son importance dans la
création du pays et elle demeure à
bagdad jusqu'à la fin de sa vie
progressivement cependant après la
création de l'irak on commence à oublier
l'importance qu'elle a eu
gertrude se remet à l'archéologie
rassemblant des collections qui
constitue le musée archéologique de
bagdad
ouvert en 1926 elle lieu d'ailleurs pour
que les trésors découverts dans ce pays
reste sur place et ne partent pas en
europe
elle ne retourne que brièvement au
royaume uni en 1925 mais déclare ensuite
qu'elle ne veut plus jamais y mettre les
pieds sans qu'on sache trop pourquoi
vers la fin de sa vie elle souffrait de
pneumonie chronique de pleurésie et
surtout elle ne se sentait pas beaucoup
d'appartenance avec ce nouveau monde a
paru à la fin de la guerre baghdad
commencé à se moderniser et le temps des
expéditions étaient loin derrière elle
elle meurt le 12 juillet 1926 très
probablement en se suicidant
barbituriques
pour ne pas finir ses jours à l'hôpital
de bagdad elle y est enterré lors de
funérailles militaires
elle reçoit aussi l'ordre britannique et
son testament permet la création de
l'école britannique d'archéologie d'irak
lawrence d'arabie ne peut pas assister à
ses funérailles parce qu'il est
ambitieux en inde à ce moment là mais il
écrit une lettre à ses parents sur
laquelle je terminerai cette vidéo et
j'espère qu'elle vous a plu je pense
qu'elle est heureuse dans la mort car
son oeuvre politique était achevée comme
la mienne
l'irak est une belle construction même
si cela ne dure que quelques années
comme je le crains et parfois l'espère
un gouvernement c'est un cadeau douteux
à donner à des gens qui n'ont jamais eu
bien sûr c'est vous qui êtes les plus
malheureux de ne plus avoir gertrude
mais enfin elle n'était pas à vous
enthousiaste intéressé toujours
passionné par les rencontres et les
événements du jour
elle laissait une impression de
perpétuels fraîcheur plus exactement
quel que fût sa fatigue elle reste est
capable d'intéresser et de capter
l'attention de quiconque venait la voir
je ne pense pas avoir jamais connu
personne qui fut si totalement civilisé